shooting a rocket launch is is very
challenging because there's millions of
pounds of thrust
this vehicle is accelerating from zero
to 75 miles an hour in 300 feet going
straight up it blows its pieces that are
not well tied down very very far away
with a lot of force when we went to
Kazakhstan to film the first piece of
the International Space Station being
launched we got the camera in place
we're probably a hundred feet from the
base of this proton rocket that's going
to launch and everything's fine we've
got sandbags piled on top of it and we
throw that morning and we pat it on its
little head make sure things all right
right before launch go away the rocket
launches and we come back and I look at
the front of the camera and there's
glass laying all in front of the camera
and it's what used to be our lens port
that we shot out of oh no it's been hit
and it's been hit really hard so we
opened up and sure enough the lens port
shattered glasses everywhere though the
filter in front of the lens is broken
but the lens itself is not broken the
lens is intact so I'm well at least
we'll still have an image of something
this is a one time launch I mean they
only launch it once it's up it's gone
you don't get take two so hopefully
we've got enough of it fortunately we
have a little tape recorder running
inside the camera to record the
viewfinder footage so we could see what
we got and sure enough the rock hit hit
the lens just about a half a second
after the rocket cleared the frame so we
got the entire rocket launched and then
this big rock in the face and it was so
dynamic that we left it in the movie
you